one of the things that's really helping
is this I love this is just a diffuser
and I'm looking every day
tea tree oil this is so important to
tree ornaments antiviral and
antibacterial so every day Fitness of us
they're going to switch it on on my burn
teacher or eucalyptus and peppermint I
have this one in my kitchen
have this one in my bedroom is where I
can set to go off after six hours and I
burn them all day because I want to help
my lungs I want to help my chest and you
couldn't smoke this if you feel a bit
congested you can put a tiny drop just
one tiny drop in water and drink it but
if you've got a family at home this is
so good for the airf it's what your
children are breathing in
so tea tree oil is amazing get it while
you still can if you haven't at least it
doesn't matter just take a little bowl
of water put in 15 drops of this and put
it on your radiator you can actually put
it straight on to a radiator because the
heat will defuse the oil but a bowl of
water is a great thing if you have a
fire you can have it near fire and
there's lots of ways you can do this you
can even just boil the kettle and have
it in little bowls you can put it on the
stove you don't have a radiators in your
house put it on the stove and just
semanas and for a couple of hours every
day so I'm a big fan of walls I also
think this is great tcp oil all of us
oil i love if you
symptoms like headaches and sniffles
it's a great thing to just sniff this
rub it on your head and heat if you feel
anything in your chest put a hot water
bottle on your chest use some vapor rub
so this is one of my key lines you know
the problem with this virus as there is
no vaccine there are nine medications
that we can really take apart from the
obvious paracetamol but this is my
favorite thing to take secondly I'm
gonna really recommend that you take
supplements I'm gonna tell you the key
ones and these are really really
important
not only now when the virus is around
but even when the virus has gone back to
normal what can you do to stop yourself
getting a weak immune system well you
want to take some supplements you want
to take a vitamin D and you want to take
5,000 IU's that means international
units that's a lot if you read different
only the theories different
recommendations I say 400 800 up to
5,000 in these times start at 5,000
5,000 IU's that is mandi a thousand of C
I don't love this brand of it women see
because it's sort of sugar I like these
ones that you put in water that you
ingest they're much better but honestly
at the moment any vitamins better
and think this is so important for
Kolb's for viruses you always wanted to
exam and want to take about 50
milligrams of thing today that may seem
a lot you see when you look at the
recommended dose for any supplements or
vitamins that's recommend for someone
who is eating well is not stressed and
isn't living a word pollution if you're
stressed all kind of stressed right now
you're not eating well if you're around
pollutants you need more so I would
really recommend you eat a lot yesterday
was a big milestone in our family
because not only have we been self
quarantined for over a week together but
we got news that one of our daughter's
friends has tested positive for the
corona virus that means our family is
now officially one person away from
having a positive diagnosis and there's
no doubt in my mind that my family is
probably all infected with it right now
why well because the daughter that I'm
talking about spent her entire Spring
Break with this person and then went
back to school for a week with this
person who she is with every single day
so there is now no doubt in my mind that
I probably have it my kids probably have
it my husband probably has it and knock
on wood
nobody is symptomatic at the moment my
daughter has a slight cough but here's
what I've noticed I've been assuming
that I have the corona virus because we
take the Mel Robbins show which is a
daytime syndicated talk show that airs
on television five days a week still
airing all the way through September
tune in because there were so many CBS
employees in our building between 60
minutes and CBS News that tested
positive and they shut down the CBS
broadcast Center where I work so I just
kind of assumed but I'll tell you
something when you get the news that
somebody that is one degree from you has
tested positive it's amazing how your
mind screws with you because my mind
immediately went boom on my chest is
tight oh my gosh
if you list like I started to feel the
panic coming on and so it's really
important that as you go day-to-day that
you continue with the advice that we
gave you about staying resilient that
you continue to police your mind that
you continue to stick to your routine to
give yourself some predictability
because with the news that's both
personal because this is personal news
and the news that you're going to see
out in the world
there will be things that trigger you
and so continuing to practice the skills
of not letting those thoughts hijack you
and not making yourself hysterical is
critical for your mental and physical
health when we're focusing on fear and
we're focusing on the media and whatever
you that's going on I think it's
important to know what's going on and
also your brain that has this algorithm
it's kind of like Instagram where if you
just like all the in all the cat videos
or cat pee you know posts Instagram is
going to show you more of those cat
posts you know how it works and so your
life is like that also you have part of
your brain that's called a reticular
activating system and so if you start
focusing on everything that's dark you
know you get the framing Opik and then
you miss the other thing it just shows
you everything that's dark
it's that same algorithm and then you
miss positivity you missed what you
could be grateful for you missed the
blessings you missed the opportunity
you're praying primarily is a deletion
device your brain is primarily a
deletion device so it's always trying to
keep information out because there's 1
billion stimuli you could pay attention
to right now so it only lets a certain
number of that in very small consciously
you could keep it pay attention to I
start this book with a quote from a
French philosopher and that says life is
the sea between the B and the D life is
the C between the B and the D and you're
thinking Jim you're speaking in tongues
you're speaking in code what on earth
are you saying I'll give you a hint B is
birth what's D
death see which is life C stands for
choice and life light comes down to
choices and I believe difficult times
right now really are gonna reveal who we
are as human beings it reveals our
character anyone could be you know
really awesome when things are going
good when they're happy when they're
healthy when when the stock market is
great everyone could do that but it's
under time of duress that that character
really is revealed and it's also built
and I would say difficult times they
could they could diminish us difficult
times can define us or difficult times
can develop us we decide we decide we
have choice right choice between the
birth and the death we have choices and
I say we as opposed to two individuals
you know kiss together it's it's so
corny team or a team global team right T
EAM together everyone achieves more and
we can get through this together
staying positive you know it's
interesting when when you hear that
typical advice is mostly people like
telling you it's not so bad you should
like think about positive things there
other people worse off than you I've
never really found that to be helpful or
convincing never I'm not saying that it
doesn't work for others but for me I
found it helpful to accept what was
going on accept reality and then make a
plan and I'll share some examples of how
I do that but I do think positivity is
not just about smiling and thinking of
people worse off than you quite the
opposite it's actually being candid with
what's going on it's focusing on what
you can control and it's also
remembering that you can serve others
which can actually help you become more
positive and forward-looking we
announced this plan it's a hundred
million dollar program to give grants to
small businesses around the world and
especially in cities is that our
employees live and work and in the idea
is just to fund help with the recovery
right so part of this grants that that
you can use for whatever is is useful
for your business
part of his tools in order to be able to
use the internet and and and our tools
to build our attract and reached new
customers and speak to the customers
that you already have to make sure that
you can keep on growing even if there's
an economic downturn and um so I I
posted about this yesterday on Facebook
and the link is in the posts that I put
there now but if you want to apply for
the program we're gonna basically be
funding 30,000 small businesses in in in
a number of cities around the world so
it sounds like if you're if you're
running a small business then you're the
type of focu of folks do we have in mind
for this and we want to make sure that
we can do our part to support small
businesses and growing and and and kind
of staying that this base of support for
the economy in our local communities if
you want more advice wisdom guidance
from other successful entrepreneurs on
how you can navigate the coronavirus
situation check out the video right
there next to me I hope you find it
valuable and continue to believe and
I'll see you there I'm telling you for
those that seek the opportunity and
what's happening right now you will find
it